as a young indian woman i've always been
aware of arranged marriages from my
family but
how do they work now and can they be
modern
how will i get married that's the
question i'm asked not when
how so when i explain that no i'm not
having an arranged marriage
but i can if i want one people are often
shocked
the reaction isn't so surprising for
those unfamiliar with the concept
an arranged marriage might mean
something like this
from what i've heard like women being
kind of forced into
marriages sad really i think in today's
world if you see
you've seen a lot of women that you feel
perhaps haven't had the choice
it shouldn't be in the modern modern age
to me that's not that's not right it's
not the way forward
in the west an arranged marriage is
often confused with the forced marriage
where the bride or groom enters into a
marriage without giving their consent
we should establish that a forced
marriage is illegal
an arranged marriage is when your family
helps you to find a partner
they make an introduction but the rest
is up to you
arranged marriages always involve
consent and they happen
all over the world they're common in
africa
the middle east and south asia and in
india
it's estimated that 90 of all marriages
are arranged
but the fact that a young person
educated in the west would choose to
have an arranged marriage over a free
choice or love marriage
might seem puzzling to some so i come to
leicester to find out why 29 year old
rosanne is happy
for her parents to find her a partner i
get shown a picture
if i like it or not sometimes even if
i'm like well
it's okay i'm not quite sure my dad's
like well let me just come to the house
talk to them
you know and then you see there's
anything that you know if you're
compatible your
person is interesting and then take it
from there only
if your parents have got a certain idea
or
a person like it's not gonna hurt
they're not going to
you meet you go into room and they
literally force you to kind of
you're marrying right now like you do
have a choice there is free will
you know and you're just in a kind of a
relaxed environment
bit of food on the table hopefully it's
been available i like to eat
so you know you can have some food you
can just talk and it's just normal
for azan she believes her parents can be
trusted to pick her a good spouse
without the influence of lust or emotion
which she says has hurt her in the past
and actually for most of history
marriages have been formed for pragmatic
reasons
rather than for love in england the
institution of marriage was more of a
union of rank and property
and parents valued security for their
daughters over romance
among aristocracy and royalty where
wealth and inheritance are involved
arranged marriages have been practiced
for centuries
you know ranged marriages have been and
are deeply entrenched
practices and have been and are common
in many families and households and many
families see that as a religious
obligation a religious duty
so many cases that i've dealt with where
young women
have disclosed that they feel that
they've had to honor the the love of
their parents
and put their own love on hold of course
the ties that bind
are incredibly strong and they can
pull and push individuals into
adhering to cultural expectations it's
almost seen as
that you shouldn't marry for love that
that
that love comes after marriage to find
out more from someone who's had an
arranged
marriage i'd come to a sweet shop in
manchester to meet nhs worker
nagma nagma had her marriage arranged in
pakistan when she was 29
before moving to england with her
husband he said that you'd had an
arranged marriage
and it was something you told it has to
work and you're always expecting
to have an arranged marriage what was
that like
and do you think it's changed my husband
came from
england and he was from long distance
family member
my granddad said that's it
and i got married in few days like a
week
i was working in school and i went to
give my resign and i said i am leaving
because i'm getting married on this
friday
my marriage was was a range and but me
and my husband brought up
like that that we have to work this
marriage so we
we are okay now we can understand each
other and we know what we want
but children now they want to have
understanding with
each other first before the marriage so
this is very important for them
for nagma her marriage was arranged
through family connections
another method involves a couple meeting
through a matchmaker
sometimes known as a rishta aunty bashar
said eunice says that the coronavirus
pandemic has put technology
at the forefront with families now
turning to marriage websites
social media groups and apps to browse
through profiles
you know during coving we've had people
literally over zoom you know families
they've got to know each other
and then even almost over zoom they've
had in a car which is the islamic
marriage so
it's really kind of good to see and you
know their goal is once
the world's back to normal and kobe
dover will have a proper wedding you
know so
it's really nice to see and i think one
really good thing is
it's made it even easier for people to
get married shahzad yunus is the founder
of a muslim dating app
he believes that technology is the best
way for families to connect now
and he's critical of traditional
matchmaking
the online world of matchmaking isn't
that easy to navigate either
there's a lot out there there's even
groups dedicated
just for doctors or just for engineers
and even for castes
and in these groups people post bio
datas it's sort of like a marriage cv
of sorts and you can include as much
information as you want
from your skin tone to even your salary
and people can also list their
requirements
for example this woman says that she
wants someone with a stable job
and no temper issues and this mother
says that she wants a girl who's at
least five foot four for her son
and modest dressing and under all of
their information
they list no time wasters with the rise
of online dating
there is a trend of assisted marriages
some kind of hybrid marriage practices
that are
really taking off there's almost like an
economic approach
to marriage these days and also about
the transactional aspect of it
from what i've seen online women are
treated as though they have a shelf life
i rarely see men searching for women
older than 25
reach 26 and your marriage profile might
come with assurances that you look
younger
for dentist jamshade monsieur nagma's
son he's tried meeting women through
family connections
and through apps and whatsapp groups but
he's yet to find someone he connects
with
now when you've said that my mum's
trying to find me someone my dad's
trying to find me someone it's like
copy and paste a profile send it to
jam's whatsapp
and then i'll open it up and then it's
like all right okay so i have to analyze
this
almost and he's like oh okay i really
don't know what to say
because i'm not doing it in a organic
way it's very synthetic
but at least there's the scope for them
to say right
here's this person's number speak to
this person on whatsapp
you know rather than just right meet up
family are going to prepare a dinner i
don't know what i'm walking myself into
and then by the end of it you know you
it doesn't make you feel good you know
jazz you
you you're left almost if you don't get
to the next stage
it's like you've just spent two three
hours in a household
and made to feel like you're not good
enough
you know it's not nice for anyone this
culture
parents worry even more about stuff like
this i think
rather than other cultures because it's
like oh my god jam
you know you're this age what's going to
happen how you you need to sort your
life out
i care a lot from my parents and i
respect them
and i don't want them to be sad or
unhappy just like any other
decent son or daughter but at the same
time there's
i just cannot sacrifice that part of
myself you know for the reasons to make
them happy i don't know whether i'm
willing to just do that
arranged marriages have been a
long-standing tradition in south asian
culture
passed down through generations and for
many
they ensure that marriage is based on
religious and cultural principles
but that's not to say they always have a
happy ending
sirama mood khan had her marriage
arranged in pakistan
when she was 18. we were we basically
was like a honeymoon period when i was
in pakistan
so you know everybody would come and see
the bride give gifts you know just go
to dinner parties they invite you around
so it was just about dressing up and
eating nice and
just exploring when he came to the uk
that's when we couldn't really connect
there was respect there and there was
everything there
but it was it was like not for me
eventually their marriage ended in
divorce
but what happens if you want an arranged
marriage and there's no obvious path for
you
the thing is that like mostly arranged
marriages like happen like between like
a man and a woman so like it
like it actually is like very
heteronormative sonrado says he would
like to have an arranged marriage
but as a gay androgynous man there are
limited options for him
i think like most south asians believe
that like queer people aren't like i
don't know
worthy enough of like being part of like
a traditional custom or like a
of like a long standing tradition and
stuff like that which is like quite
saddening
i really like want this to like change
and stuff but it's just like
not the case at the moment because like
india like so basically
the like gay rights were like made legal
like in india back in 2018 and stuff
but people like the society still like
hasn't like accepted like
people who are queer people who are gay
so you still like wouldn't like see like
any
arranged marriages in like india like
for gay couples
speaking to some rideau helped to
highlight that for arranged marriages to
keep evolving
they have to be inclusive
yes i don't mind because my parents will
always do good for me
so i don't mind doing arranged marriage
i think it's better for me as well
if you're okay with it if you can't find
your loved one
if you're not having a partner it's fine
but for me personally i found my partner
we met around five years ago so i would
not prefer arranged marriage
do you think an arranged marriage can be
modern
no if the name changes to introduction
no no no
okay that's it it's all about the luck
because sometimes arranged marriages can
walk out sometimes
love marriages workouts sometimes
neither one of them can work out so it
just depends on a lot
mine was an arranged marriage and it's
lasted 30 years
so in that way it's a good thing but
nowadays it's all changed
now they meet people at uni uni college
and you know decide for themselves which
i think is okay now
culture is not static cultures are not
static and
you know the communities that the
asperger communities i've worked with
they're continuing continually evolving
you know we shouldn't
assume that all asian families are the
same and all communities are the same
we need to recognise and also celebrate
diversity within there are individuals
who are not married who actually are in
a relationship
they are in a relationship and they
don't have children they are
in same sex relationships and i think
some parents are having to sit with
themselves
actually literally sit with themselves
and
having to lean in into the times that
we're in
because you see the harm that's done by
saying
the ties that bind means that it's my
way
or the highway well that comes at a cost
although explaining arranged marriage
seems simple enough
i've discovered that the actual process
is far more complex
young people now have a variety of
options that weren't available to their
parents and grandparents generation and
yet
the process can be alienating for those
who aren't deemed worthy enough to take
part and for those who are trying to
navigate their own preferences
and that of their families
[Music]
[Music]
you